so I'm going to be talking about a paper
that was written a few years ago with my
student Zara tougher golly the starting
point of our work is again the beautiful
result by Petrescu that shows a
connection between threesome and listing
triangles let me start by defining exact
with the problems about triangles that
will be important in this work and we
have seen them already but I'm going to
present them in a slightly different
angle so the most basic problem is
perhaps that of detecting if there's a
triangle in integral ok so I'm going to
call this detect angle ok so you're
given as input graph with M edges so the
graph is parametrized by the number of
edges and it may be sparse and you want
to know if there is a triangle
which is the same thing as asking if
there's a clique of size 3 so here a
simple result by alone used where and
shriek shows that you can solve this in
time m to the 2 omega over omega plus 1
where Omega is exponent of matrix
multiplication and this thing becomes if
Omega is equal to 2 m to the four thirds
okay the problem that's more relevant
for cover is a variant of this you which
you want to list triangles and you're
going to call this list triangle and
again you're given a graph with M edges
and you want to list m triangles so it
may be that the graph has fewer than m
triangles in the case you are just asked
to list all of them it is possible to
parameterize this problem by how many
triangles you want to list however for
all the points that I am going to make
having this number to be M is sufficient
and here there is a recent result by
your clone peg Basilica Williams and
trick
right bigger okay I'll do that thanks
and tweak that gives the same bound okay
so same so again they get em to the two
Omega over Omega plus 1 which becomes em
to the four thirds if Omega sequel to
okay all right so and now i can tell you
about this result by paris go again so
it shows that this bone here is tied for
listing triangles as human a threesome
is hard okay so blasco shows that so if
listing triangle is in time and to the
four thirds minus some constant a minus
omega 1 then threesome is also in time
and to the 2 minus omega of one ok so
again this time would be that tight III
some replies quadratic time so in this
work we were interested if you could
give reduction in the opposite direction
and that's what we obtained so in this
work
we show that if threesome is in time n
to the 1 plus epsilon then then you can
list triangles time em to the four
thirds minus plus order of epsilon right
so this result does not give anything if
threesome is just barely below quadratic
time you the substantial improvement to
get to get anything if threesome happens
to be in a later time and then you get
an algorithm for listing triangles which
runs in time em to the four thirds which
is the same running time that was
achieved in this recent work and a
different assumption namely that the
Omega is equal to 0 to both petrescu in
our work actually came before this
improvement or listing triangles before
we now have anything which courage and
to the four thurs he given if Omega is
equal to root oh okay so so what
motivation for his work is that we've
seen a number of others results which
are based on the 3sum conjecture so it
seems natural to ask what you can do a
3some happens too busy okay so I don't
know many such things and here we show
that you can get something about trainer
listing and but rizzi but there is
another which is less obvious motivation
which is the one about variance of a
threesome I mean justice shall be here
and so variance of treason so when we
consider the problem which I'm going to
call the 3x or okay which is the same
thing as 3 summer but over the domain GF
2 to some poverty okay so i can write
that as given an N by or drug order of
log n GF 2 matrix do three rows some 20
okay so each row would be one of the
elements in your input then you want us
there are three elements the sum to zero
so a challenge that I want to raise is
the what is this one
relate threesome and 3x or we're not the
first one to look at varian solid three
salmon going to mention the other works
in a second but I don't know whether
works the concern with just three with
some subject so so what's the most basic
possible relationship rule out that the
threesome is as hard as possible and
three stories as easy as possible and so
he'll specific challenge rule out that
threesome requires quadratic time
the 3x or is in linear time or vice
versa okay we don't even know how to do
goodies so what do we do we show that so
in this work we show that if this
strange look in Scenario holes so if
this holds a fifth reason super hard the
battery sir is super easy then then list
in triangles has complexity exactly
meaning both upper and lower bound end
to the voters Here I am suppressing pas
logarithmic factors so how is this shown
so the proof idea is very simple to
explain so we are going to we can
execute the reductions for 3x or
so both the reduction in Paris ghost
pepper and reduction in your paper works
just as fine if you're dealing with six
or instead of a threesome okay so that
means that in that scenario this would
be the complexity of listen triangle why
is that because if this thing was any
faster than that then by petracic us
result you will get a Socratic timer for
its rhythm and the fact that the trick
story is near time means the complexity
is not higher than a dish and the same
thing holds if you swap the roles of
these two
so what I'm going to do now is to oh
yeah so I want to mention the reasons
why this challenge may be interesting so
let's look at the variants of
disturbance when the numbness Salmons is
larger than 3 so if you look at
threesome and you obtain the problem
subsets some okay which is np-hard given
a bunch of numbers you don't have some
subset sum to 0 if you do the same thing
for a twix order you get subset X or
which is easy okay forgive you a key
metrics and you want to know if some
subset of the Rose sums 20 just eat just
asking if the rows are dependent or not
in the Kevin done in polynomial time
this is in a p on the other hand if i
look at K XOR and k is part of the input
so give you a matrix give you a matrix
and ask you if there is a linear
dependence with exactly key elements
this thing is hard this is np-hard and
that's because it allows me to know the
minimum distance of the code which is an
np-hard problem and the result work that
looks you know at this type of variance
of treason when number of segments is a
grudge and that's by bhattacharyya my
server indic woodruff and share okay
they look at you know the case i'm over
fq for arbitrary fields fq and they
you know they give tight bounds up to
polynomial assuming exponential time
about this so but as far as I know the
result does not see anything for cables
two or three
so we do now I'll give you a proof of
this this reduction let me start with
your review so the proof is in two steps
photo which are fairly Z proof for
review okay so the first step is to show
that if threesome is in time and into
the 1 plus epsilon then you can detect
triangles in time n to the 1 plus
epsilon again I'm having a bigger and
this reduction is fairly easy in fact it
was an earlier by peg MPEG ok in a
different context which we will know
about but the main technical attacking a
contribution of this work is to make
this thing deterministic the direction
is randomized we managed to draw nomas
it make this thing through mystic and
you know there is some value of making
things that the litter mystic also
because of the recent work that was
presented here at the last workshop
where they showed us some problems like
threesome and may not be strong eth hard
and for that framework you need domestic
reductions but i'm not going to see more
about this and the second step which may
be very interesting one shows that if
you can detect triangles and time
and we 1 plus epsilon then you can list
triangles
in time em to the four thurs plus order
of epsilon so if you combine these two
things you get this reduction and this
one here the second step follows closely
another argument by Basilica Williams
and Williams where they give a senior
reduction but for dense graphs so a
contribution of this work if you have a
single reduction but the work so for
sparse graphs which is a little more
complicated sparse graphs is essential
because we are dealing here with sub
quadratic time anyway I want to make a
comment that i mentioned earlier that
they will execute the reductions or so
for the six or in particular we executed
one by Brasco so if you want to know
about Paris cost reduction they want the
variant 4x4 which is our paper is a
little easier because in the contest
thing you have linear hash functions so
if you want to learn about it you may
want to take a look at that all right is
any question about the plan
good so let me start with the second
item
so I'm going to show now that if you can
detect triangles fast then it also lists
triangles fast and I will start by
giving you know review of the earlier
approach the dimension and then I will
highlight what's what's new in our yard
work ok so the first thing is that we
are going to work with tripartite graphs
so if you have a graph here which is a
bunch of veggies like black guy it is 1
i'm going to convert it into a graph
which has three parts so I'm going to
triplicate all the notes and I'm going
to repeat each edge six times one time
for every pair of parts for example this
idea now we'll go from here to here from
here to here from here to here from here
and from here to here so this this
Reformation makes at the following
recursion easier to understand and it
just blows up the number of triangles by
a factor of the six so it does not make
a difference for listing triangle I
Williams so the approach is so is to use
recursion so we are going to are going
to split each one is called partition we
want to partition each part into ok so
I'm going to take a subset of the notes
here subset here a subset clear and this
gives me
aight sub problem so once a problem will
be the one in with abdul of edges whose
endpoints a full here here and here and
there is seven others and then you
regards each sub-problem and we make our
salute puddings so the first thing is
that the you only regards on a problem
if it does contain a triangle and for
that you use the triangle detection
algorithm so only regards if there
exists the triangle and the second thing
is that the since we are interested in
listing em triangles I'm just going to
keep around M sub problems so only keep
and sub problems
right so now I'm going to make an
assumption and then tell you how the
proof will be finished on the dress
option so let me assume that each
subproblem has em over four edges okay i
will tell you later how this thing can
be insured in this case you can finish
the roof as follows and finish as
follows so I just want to use capture to
give you a sense of how the Inga ties
together so they create I'm bringing she
continued here so the time AG algorithm
would be so every time you reduce the
number of edges by factor of four so
it's a sound goes from zero to log base
4 of em oh SI where si is the number of
subproblems
at the recursion level by and for each
of these I'm calling the triangle
detection algorithm on a graph which has
em over 42 di edges 50 is the triangle
projection time and then what you use
about S sub I is the following so so so
the idea here is to please spread the
salmon too and so yeah so if when I this
index here is small then you just use
the fact that s sub I is at most aight
to the eye with every time you have
eight subproblems and if I is large then
we use the fact that since we want you
just want em triangles we only keep em
sub problems so we use that SI is the
most m and if you just pick the right
threshold for a small and large you will
get this time on em to the four thirds
donation earlier ok that's the whole
proof under the assumption that every
time thus a problem has a more four
edges and again this thing is a
basically from the previous paper by
bacillus k williams and williams and our
main contribution is to port this to the
sparse setting and an internal they mean
hurdle for that is the assumption that
each subproblem has to exactly MF edges
so in in their context that the graph
was denser so you just
split the notes in half anything is
automatically guaranteed for the right
for the port for that measure for us
it's not so so [ __ ] but it's not
particularly hard how we ensure
assumption
okay so so let's so first of all we are
going to pick the partition at random
that's what it's gonna toss a coin to
decide which side it is building so the
partition is random each node makes a
coin now let me consider one specific
sub problem and so fix a sub problem i'm
going to call s ok so what is this for
example is you know the collection of
veggies you know whose endpoints
correspond to note that always a flip 20
ok so he r denotes a flip 000 so that
that evoke respond to is a problem EG
nodes with coin 0 0 1 0 and at zone all
right so can we also define exits a b2b
the indicator variable of whether the
edge e-business so actually is the one
FG g is less than 0 otherwise ok so the
expected size of the sub-problem s is a
more for ok it's obviously the sum of
the X I which is a more for
so we are good in the expectation but we
want to ensure that each subproblem has
a more four edges so we would like like
that the expectation of the size of us
is concentrated around its expectation
is concentrated we have this internal it
would be enough if the variables X abhi
where paper wise sin pennant so would be
enough if the xB were very wise
independent because because then I can
use a Chevy Chevy inequality in argue
concentration however the variables are
cannot this is false or for example you
would have a situation like like this
now the information that it is not
belongs to some part will affect the
potential images or about images so so
what we do to rid of this we we have a
initial phase of the algorithm in which
we will go through high degree nodes and
agree notes we list they're triangles
and then we move all those notes and
this is very similar towards them and
also in our algorithms you handled
separately the ones of agree after
curious you don't have extreme
situations however exe XIV may still not
beat pairwise independent because for
that you need to remove prematurely
however they are almost so so the x DX
vr not pairwise independent but have
limited dependence ok I remove the high
degree notes so each variable here and
now it's just going to affect you know
em over a million other notes and lets
you have to carry through and we argue
in russia bishop in avadi but limited
dependence and this is enough for sure
bishop
and he should the concentration that you
want okay so and if you want to make
this thing deterministically we use a
standard almost pairwise independent
sample space and go to every seed and
chai every partitioning a pick the best
one
any question about this so that's it for
part two so now I will hang above part 1
so here we have shown how if you can
detect triangle fast signal so distant
past now we'll show you that if
threesome is fast was in time and the 1
plus epsilon then detect triangles in
time M the 1 plus epsilon alright so as
I mention earlier this basically on my
idea is often this paper by peg and a
peck of doing a different context so he
is serious oh so we're given graph so
we're gonna pick random integer X mu for
every node okay and then the threesome
instance is is the following this is an
instance would be the set of numbers X
sub u minus X sub B such that the XV is
an edge in a graph so here I'm thinking
of the graph is being directed doesn't
matter if the graph is undirected you
can write that static graph with edges
in both directions so for it for the
analysis so clearly if there exists the
triangle then the corresponding three
numbers will sum to zero because
everything will they cancel out if there
is no triangle then every three numbers
that you pick will give you we
correspond to a nonzero
linear form in the mini axis and so with
high probability over the choice of the
assignment so the axis would be clumsy
oh ok so any three numbers you know it's
a nonzero linear form phenomenon and so
you get non zero with very high
probability and you can do a Union bound
over all possible choices for this three
numbers any questions about this ok just
so
now we'll tell you how this thing we
made to domestic we make it domestic the
bottom line here is to find the
collection of numbers which have
non-trivial solution to a certain type
of equations okay so so need collection
numbers with no non-trivial solutions
until allah means that the numbers are
not repeated to this equation here x1
plus x2 plus x3 is equal to x 4 + 65
plastic 6 ok so that's the devil
equation that you get from the sum of
the numbers here so if I the collection
on numbers which have known trivial
solutions again just assign those
numbers to my notes and if there's no
triangle you will not get a zero okay so
this seems it's something like I know
it's the bread and butter already owe me
lyrics and infected trilogy sure sure
you can sorry no I think that's no
that's that's the only 10 you know
that's your type of social event or
about you or 43 sonya four triangles so
the idea become a holics you know there
are many papers they give upper and
lower bounds on the size of such
collections however
as far as I know none of those results
give you a construction that runs fast
okay so you can extract maybe braddock
time construction of those numbers but
that would be not good enough for us
because we need to work in a bottle
linear time okay so this is not a linear
time your time construction or not even
close if a new nose of reference
otherwise let me know okay so instead so
using a different approach we show how
to use combinatorial designs to
construct to construct such collections
so we are not going to get the same
precise bounds of course on the size of
this collection that it will be good
enough for us and using a certain
construction of designs are able to
produce these numbers in real time we've
seen already several papers with more
users of common area designs and this is
this one more so design I will pick a
collection of sets and sex recipe is a
subset of a universe of size order of
log n so just think of it as a window or
the Gorgon bits in the characteristic
vector ruination and the property that i
need is that S sub I interceptors S sub
J will be at most the size of a sub I /
you know them for every I NJ so the
intersection of n 2 is fairly small
compared to the size okay and the number
of sets has to be exponential in the
universe sighs if you have this then
we'll do then you know my number X I you
know has the decimal representation
which is equal to s toboi so then why is
decimal representation as our imitation
of X sub I is a is given by X sub I ok
so just think of the sets and put zeros
and ones for X sub I and now I claim
that with this area you don't have any
solution to good thing and why is that
because pick any candidate solution
let's look at example text sets up the
six this is sunset and it has one in
certain places and 0 in others and when
you make this some there will be no care
in the decimal representation so it's
all a matter of whether the ones that
appear here in possibly cover the one
therapy array can exist and that's not
gonna happen because i have this
requirement here so what do we know
about constructions so the first
construction of designs with these
parameters explicit is in the cemetery
by Nissan and bitter some but again
that's agreed because that's an
iterative construction we shall scream
which has a time exponential em why we
need positing NM so we use a different
construction which you have we have in
this paper from a while back with a good
friend which you know we can get about
parameters and time order of em ok the
construction which is based on combining
error correcting codes with designs
which are obtained and be a brute force
but I'm not you details now
and that's it for me thank you any
questions
the state any questions by the second
thank you